[Music]
I really hate being a mom Hate's a
really heavy word tell me about that
before I had my daughter I just remember
just being like I don't I don't want to
have a kid I don't want her to be like
me I don't want her to grow up the same
way as me you're trying to do different
things cuz you hate the way you
[Music]
feel what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show it's a show about your
marriages your
relationships your mental health
whatever you got going on your life
parenting dealing with kids and their
schools and their teachers and whatever
else you got going on in the world we
are here to help um this shows real
people going through real stuff right
this is not manufactured this isn't us
just making up things this is not
episodic writing these are real people
with struggles from all over planet
Earth people calling from all over the
place trying to figure out what to do
next next and so if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at 84469 33291
or go to johal.com
[Music]
askas and man it makes such a huge
difference if you just hit the Subscribe
button such a big difference if you just
hit the Subscribe button uh roll over to
YouTube and hit the Subscribe button
there or whatever you're listening to
this on podcast just take a second knock
it out it makes such a huge huge
difference um also I hope your New
Year's going all right
we're a month in I guess a month
month-ish in month and a week it's not
too late to get back on the horse it's
not too late everybody's got great
intentions and then it gets dark and
miserable and cold it's not too late to
go all right kind of blew that first
month let's get back on it let's get
back on it all right let's go out to
Springfield Illinois and talk to Lois
Lane what's up
Lois hi there Superman yeah yes I knew
it I'm GNA clip that make my daughter
listen to it what's
up well speaking of New Year's
resolutions and whatever mine was to be
more honest with myself uh oh that
usually comes with a lot of
yikes I stirred the pot that's for sure
yeah you did so my question is how can
my husband and I of 32 years communicate
better so that we don't so that we can
interpret each other smoother oo I I
actually this is going to sound
embarrassing there's two sentences that
will change I don't even know what
you're about to say there are two
sentences I'm going to teach you that
will change everything in your house
but the more important part is will you
and your husband actually do this so
tell me tell me the story tell me the
story of this romance and how we ended
up here okay um so way back in my
college days um I met my cousin
roommate and before I even met him I was
interested just because he was the right
age and anyway so it was um easy for me
to know that he was the one and I was
his first and only girlfriend gross
gross like a Dawson's Creek episode all
right so yes y'all looked at each other
across the room the Titanic music
started playing y'all it happened and
then what uh so we uh did everything in
the right order we graduated from
college waited a little over a year to
get married waited four years to have
kids um and we
waited uh because he didn't he wasn't me
and he got tired of me asking every five
seconds can we have kids can we have
kids now so finally I wore him down and
uh my first one was prey 1B 11 o and I'm
like I don't think I'm ready for this
but turned out wonderful and then two
years later we had a second daughter and
that was going to be it for me I'm like
obviously I need to just limit to two so
basically we just had the ideal life and
he was he's an engineer and I'm an
accountant and um God I bet your
romantic talk is
just
God but we're two different types of
nerds so I like the big picture and he
likes the fine
details and I like the bottom line but
also want to know what did I overspend
on my you know grocery budget because
I'm still buying groceries for the the
grown girls because I go up to see them
and I go out grocery
shopping anyway so there's this we're in
a different phase of life now that is
just the two of us and he we were able
able to uh retire early um because of
Dave and listening to him back in
2011 I finally got on the bandwagon and
decided that I didn't have to laugh at
my husband wanting us to pay cash for a
car and uh so even though I was an
accountant I didn't really know personal
finance so and so my husband is just
like who is this Dave
and let's let's just do it you know
so anyway um so bring me bring me to
right now yeah right now it's
like we're in a different phase of life
and I think we
haven't communicated to each other what
we want retirement to be
like and so every little thing um gets
misinterpreted or we both like to be
right and so we don't trust what the
other one's saying okay you
you want to give you an example well
I'll take one in a minute but I want
just to sit in something really
uncomfortable we're all telling the
truth right yes right and you've
listened to the show before so I wish I
had like two hours just to hang out and
have a margarita with you I bet we would
laugh our heads off but um and I would
pay for it of course because you're an
accountant but I I I want us to be able
to like just cut to it so
um when you just painted me a picture
how long have you been married 32
years not one time did you talk about
how much you like that guy or your
romance you laid it out like it's in an
Excel
spreadsheet
and I'm I I don't have any literature on
this um so I'm overgeneralizing it I'm
actually making something up so I'm sure
if somebody has a study I would love to
read it but I can't imagine
that sexual intimacy
like just gooey gross romance just oozes
out
of an engineer married an
accountant and so you got it what you
just laid out for me
is yall built a really um functioning
good profitable business
together and I will applaud
you but man
I hope you didn't miss out on the good
stuff is that fair yeah does that hurt
to hear
that
um it's emotional because that's what
I've been asking for yeah for a long
time I'm
sorry is it something that um your
husband couldn't give you and what I
mean by that is he didn't have the
skills he didn't know what he's doing or
is it something he was like nope I'm not
you don't get that from
me H yeah he says that a lot what's
that but that's not that's not his style
that's
um he he just doesn't know how to have
fun okay give me an example of something
there's something happened recently
that's why you would call so tell me
what that would be I'm assuming that
something happened yeah
so it was just a week ago I was going to
run some errands and and then go to
Bible study and then it' be home and one
of the errands was to pick up an
order um and I thought the place would
be open till 10 because it usually is
open till
10:00 and when I got there at 9:10 it
was closed and then it took me an hour
to go grocery shopping and got home at
11:00 and he's like what took you so
long I was like well I was was trying to
pick up the order for you and I said but
they had already closed and I said if I
had known what time they closed I would
have been home a lot sooner I wouldn't
even gone grocery shop you I but have
waited some other
time and he says well I told you that
they were going to close earlier the
nine and I
said I said but you didn't I said you
thought they closed at six on a Saturday
or W I don't know what day was anyway I
guess it was a Wednesday night okay so
so I said I did talk to an employee and
normally they are open till 10: but when
the time changes they close at 9:00
until the time changes again and then
they CH close at
10:00 and he said that he saw right on
the app that they closed at 9: why
didn't I see it I said because when I
opened the app I was already there I
said I didn't have time to look it up
ahead of
time and the fact that he knew knew that
they closed at 9: but didn't tell
me did he know you were going to run a
special errand for him
yes and when you asked why didn't you
tell me what did he
say he said I thought you checked the
app is that true or is he lying to
you uh he doesn't lie okay
but in his mind in his mind as Mr
engineer it would not ever occur to him
to leave the house not knowing exactly
where he's going what time they open who
the manager is where that manager went
to college like right so like that would
never even occur to him right so if you
say you Loosey Goosey accountant you if
if if you're leaving the house of course
you've checked all the
times but when you retold the story can
I tell you one thing that made me just
cringe inside
yeah is you said I went to do a nice
thing for
you I went to try to demonstrate that I
love
you and I wouldn't have if I had known
it right and then you had to get that
jab in there yeah you see what I'm
saying and then he's just got stabbed
and he's got to stab you back and now
I'm St now we're in the parking lot
fighting over like a what right yeah yep
all right so I'm gonna I'm going to be
honest with you I don't buy the that's
just not my
style when you get married you you take
a knee in front of somebody and you say
I will do whatever I can in my power to
help meet your needs it is not my style
to be on time just not I like having
conversations That's My Style my style
is making somebody feel
hurt my style is dude when I get there
it's going to be amazing did everybody
just chill
out my style is I'm just going to wear
black t-shirts every everywhere because
it makes my life
easier then my wife says Hey I want to
go out somewhere nice it would mean a
lot to me if you dressed up now I could
say that's just not my
style you know who you married you know
what that makes me excuse my friendch
she makes me an
ass makes me a
child when she says hey
um It embarrasses me when we show up
places late all the time
oh that's not my style that's not how I
roll no dude you got it I got to change
this see what I'm saying so yeah I don't
buy his this or that okay but I also
want to dig a layer
deeper how much of this over the years
has there been explicit
instruction versus it doesn't feel as
romantic if I have to say it it's just
not romantic and if I have to say it and
explain it and teach him how to do X Y
or Z then it just doesn't doesn't feel
like it matters as much to him and it's
kind of like the thing that we tell I
tell parents all the time who have their
first kid you have to put sex on the
calendar now and I know somehow
Hollywood told you that means it's not
as good or something but you have a
toddler now so you can have no sex or
plann sex that's it that's the two
choices you got um
similarly have you spent 30 years hoping
he just gets it and then being really
mad that he didn't get it or have you
been really explicit with I need you to
love me like this cuz those are two
different
scenarios so in the last 10 years I've
tried to voice exactly what I want like
I want a foot rub every day
okay and what is it okay let's let's
take that what is a foot what does a
foot rub mean to
you uh besid besides it feels good
obviously foot rub feels good because
it's like for my health I actually need
it okay and uh it just makes my day so
much better okay and also is it kind of
cool to have the man you love for 30
three decades 30 years just kind of stop
everything and focus on you for a
minute okay yeah and skin to skin
contact is Magic and if you've watched
Pulp Fiction we all know that foot
massages are kind of erotic right all of
it right and you need it well it doesn't
even have to be erotic it's I know I'm
I'm just being silly but but but it's
but it's everything and there's
circulation issues so um and what does
he say I'm not doing
that or does he do
it
um I usually have to remind him that I
really need one okay but last night he
he did it without me even asking okay
have you ever told them the layer
beneath the layer because here's here's
a perfect example somebody says hey I
need you to do X Y and Z for me I need
you to rub my shoulders because I've
been lifting weights and I've got a pain
in my shoulder MH I've just made our
exchange an Roi I've made it a a
transaction I've made it a medical
procedure um and I've got I hold all of
my stress every ounce of stress in my
life I hold it in my neck and my wife is
a master like off-grid chiropractor she
can pop my back in the in the in the
wildest ways it's awesome but I told her
once cuz I always say hey we pop my back
we pop my back we C my back one time I
told her this is years and years ago he
like it means something to me just that
moment of
connection when you're tracing down my
spine trying to figure out where that
where the where it's out when you take a
moment but when I explain to her hey
this is medically and this is
transactionally and I'm actually asking
you to pause what you're doing to like
do a chore for me also this is a moment
where we can
connect dude she has never once said
said no she will ask me she can now
watch she started watching for the way I
walk right but it was me explaining hey
there's a there's there's a level deeper
here but I think where you and your
husband sit is this let me ask you the
scary question are you g to end this
marriage are you out have you reached a
point where you're saying like I I don't
want I don't want the next 30 years of
my life to be like this no
okay so there's two sentences one is
from Dr beray Brown and the other is
from Dr William Glasser okay that have
transformed marriages all across the
country I'm gonna give them both to you
right now cool yep all of this is going
to sit on a foundation of hey husband I
want to go on a weekend retreat with you
you can bring your spreadsheets you can
bring your architectural designs you can
bring your strategic planning
tools but I want to our our life has
changed our daughters are gone
everything in our home is different and
we have to reimagine our
marriage and I don't like bickering at
you I don't like poking at you and I
don't think you like poking at me and I
know you're very smart and hopefully you
don't think I'm dumb but we've just
started talking to each other I speak in
Spanish and you talk back to me in
Italian and I want us to learn a new
language together yep German or Spanish
and German Go Spanish and German there
you go so if you sat down and and said
hey I have booked us this Retreat for
half a day for a whole day would he say
and I want to I want to reimagine our
marriage for the next 25 years because
we get to decide whether it's fun or
whether it just keeps being this would
he be happy about that or he be like oh
God another thing to
do um actually uh we did something like
that two years ago okay and uh so he's
been wanting to do something again
amazing as far as imagining it um he
just feels like we have to plow through
all the past okay before we can stream
again I think it's best to have a place
where we're
going okay so when somebody comes into a
gym and says hey my doctor told me that
if I don't lose 100 pounds I'm going to
die the personal trainer doesn't sit
there and go well all right we're going
to have to go in that back room for the
next six months and we're going to have
to figure out why you ate so much and
why you put on no we're going to start
losing weight Okay so think the best way
to kind of peel back the past in a in
and it's going to sound wild is to sit
down and ask each other 25 years from
now I'm 75 you're
75 what do we want our house to feel
like what do we want our marriage to
feel like warmth hilarious Joy
grumpy what do we want it to feel
like where do we want it to be so I want
you to paint a
picture so clear as to where you're
headed and then we're going to reverse
engineer it what has to be true for me
to come home and this thing to be warm
man I got to learn a new way to talk to
you you see how we're going to get there
that way because you two don't have the
skills to go in the back and go through
the old boxes because both of you get
ashamed both of you feel some guilt both
of you feel attacked and then you just
start knifing each other then it's over
yep right so I don't think yall have the
skills to go backwards yet I do think
based on the world you've created two
amazing daughters uh you retired early
yall can work together as a team I want
yall to work together and build imagine
this thing y'all could have in 25 years
financially romantically do y'all still
want to be 75 year old couple still
trying to figure out and have some sex
put that on the put that on the thing
put it all put all of it out there okay
and then here's the two questions
they're going to get you there okay
number one I want you both to ask the
question um or say this out loud when
you are interacting so let's take the uh
the the the situation that happened at
the
store man I got home where what took you
so long well dude I went to go pick up
that thing for you and they were closed
I know didn't you check the
app
pause honey the story I'm choosing to
make up is that you think I'm
stupid the phrase the story I'm choosing
to makeup is and that's from Dr
Brown well didn't you you know that they
close the story I'm choosing to make up
is that you think I just got in the car
in the middle of the winter and drove
around the neighborhood till 11
o'clock and vice versa he'll say the
story I'm choosing to make up up is
after our great date last night you just
don't think I'm attractive anymore and
you don't want to have sex with me and
you can go actually that's true you've
put on 75 pounds when you talk about
that I'm worried about your health or it
could be oh honey I had gas so bad while
we were eating dinner all night I was
trying so hard not to blow you out of
the restaurant like it had nothing you
see what I'm saying yeah but that phrase
the story I'm choosing to make up is you
don't think that our daughters are worth
groceries
and he can sayoh no honey you've been
taking care of them for so long my story
is they're grown-ups they need to buy
their own groceries there's nothing to
do with you but it might come out of you
see what I'm saying that's that's
sentence number one sentence number two
is what is your picture
for we speak in pictures I'm sorry we
speak in words but we think in pictures
so you both say I need you to go pick up
that thing I'm going to go pick up that
thing
cool you have a picture of what that go
what that looks like you going at 9:00
at night and then going ahead and pick
up groceries afterwards your husband has
a picture of what that looks like which
is check the app see if they're open
though they're not even open we're going
to go
tomorrow or hey we're going to go visit
the
girls well when you say that his picture
is cool we're going to make a 9-hour
drive no bathroom stops no food we're
going to get there we're going to hang
out for 24 hours we're going to come
back your picture of hey we're going to
go visit the girls same exact words are
well I'm going to swing by the store I'm
going to shop at Costco and spend $850
to make sure they don't have to buy
groceries for the next calendar year and
then we're going to spend three days
you're going to re-roof the house honey
I'm gonna make see what I'm
saying and then he gets mad that you
want to stop and you get mad that he
doesn't want to stop because you both
said we're going to go see the
girls and so before my wife and I do
anything I asked it last night hey
what's your picture of tonight look like
what's your picture of the morning look
like cuz sometimes my wife will say hey
I just I just need some space tonight
kids have been bananas and I'm like cool
after dinner after uh everything's put
away and after the kids are in bed you
don't want me messing with
you cool for her space means oh no no no
no when you walk in the door I'm I'm
leaving right you're doing dinner right
exactly so hey when she says Hey tonight
I need some and I say what's your
picture that look like and she goes yeah
at like 5:00 I'm going to go take myself
to dinner and I'm going to get some
writing done awesome dude I love
spending my night with my kids it's
chaos it's so fun I don't like feeling
like I let her down because then I feel
ashamed and I don't like feeling like
I'm failing in my own house which y'all
have probably both felt for 30
years okay those two sentences will
dramatically transform your marriage if
you're both committed to making this
thing
amazing and quote unquote this thing
amazing number one you have to sit down
and talk about what your picture of
amazing looks like and that is the
planning let's go away for a retreat and
build where are we going to live what's
our house going to look like both of
y'all take some time and get on
Pinterest or Google find some houses you
want to have are you going to move by
the girls are you going to stay here
what kind of cars are you going to have
are youall going to be fit 75 year olds
are you going to be 75 year olds I don't
give a crap anymore I'm eating pizza and
Twinkies all the what world are yall
going to be
romantically sexually financially
practically geographically what kind of
world do you want to have and then
reverse engineer it to right now what
has to be
true I'll leave you with one more thing
as y'all get start looking in the back
room at those old boxes the way all used
to treat each other the things you wish
things you regret all
that always use the word
I I want to be more intimate and I
didn't tell you or I told you but I
didn't I don't think I made it clear
enough for it I'm
sorry I wanted to do XYZ when you start
lobing you then y'all are going to have
to fight each other so make all the the
frustrations and complaints when youall
start going back in the past about I I
need this I want this I don't want to
fight you about an app
anymore I don't want to fight you about
trying to do a nice thing for you I
don't want to fight you about going to
visit the girls I don't make it about I
okay and in a passive aggressive way but
a very much I'm just telling you what I
need I think there's a lot of Hope For
You Lois Lois especially if youall get
on the same page and you say all right
we're fighting for this thing we're
building something
amazing use those two sentences to
transform
everything then you got to go do it let
me know how that Retreat goes we can't
wait to find out we'll be right
back I am all in on my latest Fitness
wearable the Apollo I'm wearing it right
now on my ankle the Apollo transforms in
changes your nervous system I want you
to hear this carefully the Apollo
wearable doesn't just record your data
and give you insights on how to improve
in certain areas the Apollo actively
helps with the transformation it changes
you for the better I wear the Apollo in
both the daytime and in the night time
it's small and nondescript and you can
wear it on your ankle your wrist or you
can just clip it to your shirt or your
pants and it gives me many of the same
benefits as other modalities like
meditation or mindfulness it sends tiny
pulses of vibration at different
frequencies depending on what I'm doing
and you know me I am as skeptical as
they come and this little device is
continuing to blow my mind because it
works if you're struggling to wind down
to fall asleep to stay asleep or have
energy throughout the day try the Apollo
Apollo is giving our show listeners 15%
off the wearable go to apollon neo.com
dealone that's Apollo a p o l l l nuro
NE
o.com dealone for 15%
off all right let's go out to welcome to
Miami and talk to Tony what's up
Tony hi how's it going John what's up
Toney I'm doing good man how about you
I'm doing well excellent what's up hey
got a question um I'm in a construction
business with my dad and my brother okay
uh my brother's 32 I'm
2 I just had uh uh we just had a kid in
November and um
congrats thank you and I'm trying to
figure out kind of The Next Step In My
Life um with the
business dad has I've worked with Dad my
whole life um I I en I enjoy the work we
do but um I I don't see he's always said
that he wants to give the company over
but um I still feel like I'm 15 and I
don't know those are two different
things brother those are two different
things okay okay there's the business
side the the the succession side the
transition side and then there's the I'm
sick and tired of being treated like a
child I'm sick of going to work every
day thinking I'm gonna disappoint my
dad yeah right or he talks to you like
you're
stupid
fair enough yeah I hate that for you man
I hate
that have you talked to him about it
probably not that's a hard conversation
to
have uh I've tried um it hasn't went I
haven't gotten too far with it yeah kind
of usually ends up in an argument
between us okay you're not going to like
my
answer I think you probably go get got
to go get another
job cuz ultimately you're going to lose
your relationship with your
father over a construction business and
that relationship's not worth
it then he's not going to
change I don't see another path forward
unless unless I'm missing
something is your brother experiencing
the same
thing yeah okay um we have a lot of
frustrations with that yeah um it's like
he doesn't hear us we we are foremans
out on the construction site and there's
a lot of things we see that are lacking
and um when we when we bring them to his
attention he he says that he's been in
the business longer than we ever have
and that he knows
best um yeah and it gets
pretty I feel like I'm disrespecting him
or letting him down if I leave the
company but you disrespect him and let
him down in his eyes every time you tell
him ways that you can do your job
better yeah you're not a foreman you're
a glorified
secretary right he wants you just to to
count heads he doesn't care what you
think he doesn't care after you're
onsite what actually should be going on
or ways you could make the company more
money or streamline things or have
better customer service he don't care
what you have to say you're an admin
dude
and then he wraps it up with look at
this big beautiful family we
have look at this big beautiful business
that I'm building for my family and he
wraps up in a bunch of family talk and
then that's just a noose around your
neck right yeah and if you try to help
out this big family business you're
betraying him you're shaming him how in
the world could his little baby boy his
child know more than he
does I would say well you trained him
and taught
him
God I would like when I'm hunting with
my son my son's 13 when he comes back
and says hey Dad don't go over that Hill
go around this Ridge I love
that his eyes work better than mine he's
got sharp little eagle eyes CU he's a
kid but your dad somehow hears that as a
threat as a
shame and so he wants his cake and he
wants to eat it
too how would I go forward in that
with him what would be the way of that I
could do it I mean for me I've given
everything I have to this company
and I'm in my heart I can I know I can
walk away from it in that
aspect um content knowing that I gave
everything I have and yeah but how how
do how do I go forward in that how do I
I don't know how to approach him that he
doesn't blow up on
me well I think there's two sides to
this number one you got to get out of
your head that you can control him at
all you can't the only person you can
control here is you your thoughts and
your actions and I think it's Noble and
I think it's
right to treat your parents with dignity
and respect even if they don't deserve
it and that doesn't mean I'm going to
stay with them forever that doesn't mean
I'm just going to be abused no dignity
and respect means I'm going to sit down
and I'm going to treat
you um with character with dignity you
can respond like a
child the way I would phrase what you're
going through is Hey Dad I need to have
a hard conversation with
you and um it's going to be hard and
it's going to be one of those things
that in the past has ended up in a uh in
a argument and I don't want to argue
with you I respect you too much can you
let me know when you got some free time
let's do it right now no now's not a
good
time can we say set up like on a
Saturday morning or something like that
Sunday
morning and I would go about it that way
and then my conversation with him your
heart's going to be beaten out of your
chest you're going to be
nervous yeah but I would let him know
hey Dad I have reached a point where I'm
struggling being both your son and your
foreman and so I'm not willing to lose
my relationship with my dad I want you
to be a Granddad to my kids I want you
to be a part of my life
and I'm struggling
to hold both of these things and so I
think the best thing for me to do over
the next few months is to find a new job
so that you can go back to just being my
dad and just being a Granddad to our new
baby and what you've done in that
situation is you've made it all about
you if he asks you well then you can
tell them well what do you mean what
would have to change what what do you
mean that's hard for me
me because at work you talk to me in a
certain way that you wouldn't talk to me
as your
son I want to be a foreman where when I
say hey we need to do this this and this
that the supervisor who hired me lets me
do my
job but only ask answer those questions
if he invites
it and it' be even better if your
brother came with
you but he's probably next in line to be
the CEO and he probably not going to do
that is
he
yeah that's the only Avenue forward I
can
see and your dad may hit the roof he may
and at that point you be like hey man
I'm gonna I'm gonna head out how dare
you I'm gonna head out
man you're a 25y old man you don't have
to sit there and listen to Somebody yell
and scream at you treat you like you're
five because you're not you're a grown
man you have a child you have a job
obviously you're very talented in what
you do
M okay how's all that sitting in with
you because you knew I was going to say
this before you even called
right that's what my wife is telling
me would she be happy with you getting a
new
job yeah
okay yeah
okay I don't know why I'm I don't know
why I feel so
pulled to be here I don't I don't know I
can tell I can tell you exactly
why cuz it's been your job to take care
of your old man your whole
life when he gets pissed off I guarantee
you he says look what you made me
do or if you had just done this this and
this then I wouldn't have had to fill in
the blank am I
right yeah yep that was never your job
that was his
job so in a weird way you've been
parenting him his whole the the whole
time you've been alive it's been your
job don't do that dad's going to get mad
you better make sure you get those
grades dad's gonna get pissed you better
be there earlier dad's going to get
that's been your whole
life and so it feels like you're
abandoning a
child cuz that's what you've been doing
your whole life you've been taking care
of his sensitive little emotions his
childish
emotions
and by the way if he was on the phone
with me right now I would tell him shame
on you it's never your child's job to
make you feel
okay it was his job to train a 25y old
and a 34 year old or 32y old however old
your brothers into the men who can run
this company and to trust them and to
take care of them he didn't do
that he has a fantasy on one hand about
this big family business which is noble
and
awesome and he's got this other
um
emotional deficiency which is it's his
boy's responsibility to make sure
everything he looks good and it's not
it's not so dud when you start to pull
away your body's gonna fight you because
your body's like dude if we leave he
goes He implodes that's his that's on
him that's on
him you got to do what's best for your
family what's best for you and quite
honestly what's best for your
relationship with your dad and it sounds
like right now you're starting to Res
sent
him every time he calls you and yelling
every time he texts you really hot
you're
like you got some skills people probably
reaching out to you man I'd love for if
you come run my Fillin the
blank I think it's worth the final
conversation but I think it's good
setting it up on the front end hey this
is going to be hard and I'm not
interested in arguing with you I'm just
coming at you manto man father to
son can we have an adult
conversation yeah sure son let's go out
it that way
way I'm proud of you Brother Andy man
maybe he's like dude I'm sorry I didn't
do this right maybe it all changes
probably not but
maybe like I said all this is this is
even more helped if your brother comes
with you maybe run it by him
first proud of you man hard hard stuff
congratulations on that new baby call
anytime brother I'm with you we'll be
right
back Today's Show is made possible by
some of the best potions and powders on
the planet organifi I first bought
organifi with my own money after several
of my brilliant muscled up friends kept
ranting and raving about how great they
were and now I take them every single
day even my wife and kids are in on it
and they're an essential part of my
Wellness routine you all know that I
take a number of supplements every
single day depending on what my goals
are and what I'm trying to accomplish
but overall organifi has helped me
reduce the number of individual
supplements I take by bringing some of
these things all together here's the
deal organifi makes every everything
easy because it's a powder that you mix
with water they also have capsule
supplements and after you drink it
you're Off to the Races off to better
digestive health or off to Deep Sleep
here's an example of some of the things
I take every day I take the green juice
and the red juice all the time the green
juice levels me out and gives me the
critical micros that I need and the red
juice gets me ready to rock and roll in
the morning without mainlining caffeine
my family and I have also been taking
immunity for daily immune support while
everyone we know has been getting sick
and not feeling organifi is hooking up
our show listener gang with 20% off all
organifi products even the kids line go
to organifi.com dealone or use promo
code deloney at checkout that's o r g n
fi.com
delone or use promo code deloney at
checkout all right let's go out to
Houston and talk to
Kayla you got me on my knees Kayla I
know it's Lea what's up Kayla
um it's good how are you good what's
going
on so um I really hate being a mom and
I'm having a really hard time with like
motherhood in general okay and I'm just
worried about like
um my marriage and then like the
relationship I'm going to have with my
daughter okay because I just it's just
really hard yeah hey Hate's a really
heavy word tell me about
that I
mean there's like nothing wrong with her
she's slept well she smiles all the
time I just I mean it's just every day
it's the same song and dance and like I
really want to like it I I sit there and
I see like how happy my husband is and
how much she just loves it and I just I
just I just can't even bring myself to
even just like
it I don't know why I and I feel
terrible because I know my husband
deserves someone who wants to be there
and my daughter deserves someone who
loves her and I love my daughter but not
in the same way that my husband loves
her can I tell you I don't know if I
fully believe
that why do you think your daughter
deserves a better mom than
you I just don't feel like I'm good
enough man I mean like you're sick of
feeling this way why don't you think
you're good
enough it's just so hard yeah it's the
it's the worst it's the
worst it's the worst it makes you just
want to curse Pinterest doesn't it yeah
and all the mommy guilt blogs that are
out
there people building accent walls with
their kids and their little slings and
Mak their sourdough bread like why do
you think you're so bad at
this I just see like how other people um
I don't give a crap about other people
what about
you I I don't know I just I just I'm not
I mean I remember before I had my
daughter I just
remember um just knowing I didn't want
kids I I just knew like my limitations
and I just knew like cuz how I grew up
was it's just like rough I mean like you
know it's not the perfect life but I
mean you know it is what it is and um I
just remember just being like I don't I
don't want to have a
kid cuz I just don't want her to I don't
want her to be like me I don't want her
to you know grow up the same way as me
and I'm I'm trying really hard to change
the things that my my family how they
raised me and stuff and it's just been
like really hard I know cuz you're
trying to make changes out of hatred
you're trying to do different things cuz
you hate the way you
feel and you're trying to do things
different because you hate the way you
grew
up and that always feels like you're
pulling a sled uphill on
ice instead of oh my gosh dude I get to
build I get to decide what this life
looks like and I'm worth more than this
and so I'm going to make it amazing
that's
sustainable it's like going to the gym
and working out cuz you hate your body
you're trying to punish yourself for
looking crappy versus dude I'm gonna go
to the gym because am worth an hour and
I want to feel
amazing one of those is going to end and
one of those is going to keep going for
forever but it sounds like you didn't
want to have a
kid because you knew how you felt all
those
years yeah I
know I mean how do I just cope with it
then I feel you don't cope you build
something
amazing
how that's what I'm asking you what do
you want your home to look
like what do you want it to feel like
let me say it that way what do you want
to feel
like like love okay what does that even
mean I just you know you come home and
you know there's like you just feel
loved and like nope break it down for me
be very specific what does love look
like because here's why you're going to
keep chasing a feeling and that feeling
is never going to get there because your
body doesn't even know what that feels
like I mean I guess just like everyone
and be and be happy is even vague itself
I don't I just want to come home and I
just want to know that everything's okay
I
guess is your husband
trustworthy yeah he is is your baby
healthy yeah are y'all broke are you
okay financially yeah we're fine
financially we do the Dave Ramsey and
everything are you do you have
uh stable
work well I'm not working I'm a stay at
home mom for right now CU you know all
right no cuz you know no that's a choice
y'all made are you lonely as all get
out I don't feel lonely I have my sister
comes over all the time um no do you
have a group of girlfriends you put the
kid and hand the kid to somebody else
and you get away for a minute no I don't
do that it's just really uh I feel
guilty if I do that okay I feel like
you're dying right now
choose guilt over resentment because
you're starting to resent your kid
you're starting to resent your husband
you're starting to resent your home
you're resenting your
life choose
guilt
okay that's fair because I think
underneath all of this you don't like
the life that
has I would say that you've created but
I don't think it was ever intentional I
think it just kept kind of happening
and when you have a kid everything gets
super real because that kid wakes up at
the same time no matter how late you
stayed up and that kid needs to eat no
matter what and that kid God they don't
stop
pooping yeah
right and then you start having
fantasies of remember
when yeah that's every day for me right
remember we had money remember we could
just have sex all the time remember when
we just went
out I miss those days
man and it's okay to miss
them but the the Assumption here is is
that that was somehow better than what
you can choose to build right
now so it's essentially like changing
your mindset then no you gotta I don't I
mean yes there will be some of that but
you're you can't just do that in a
vacuum you can't just sit on the couch
and just be like change mindset sucky
thing is now awesome and that's what
that's what is Instagram tells you to do
just change your mindset no you got to
do
differently because I don't think you
hate your daughter I don't even think
you hate being a mom I think you hate
being a mom in the world where you have
found
yourself and quite possibly you hate the
routine quite possibly you hate feeling
like your husband's doing a better job
of this than you are
quite possibly your body is beginning to
awaken little GPS pins it put in you a
long time ago that said this isn't safe
this is not
safe and your body is recognizing that
little girl and it's like here we go
she's going to be in the same crap you
are and that just gets so
exhausting I agree is that fair
yeah have you fully accepted having a
baby yet how old's this baby she's one
okay have you fully accepted I'm
in like you I'm like this is a strange
thing to say but you can't there's
nowhere to go you're a mom yeah I know I
mean yeah I
know I know I you know and I feel guilty
for him saying this but it's it's just
like there are days where I just really
want to walk away of course and I feel
terrible that makes you normal that
makes you
normal I've been snowed in at my house I
don't know anybody who's got a better
marriage than I do I don't know anybody
who's got better kids than me I love my
kids they're a
riot and we've been snowed in for the
last like four
days I was super hyped to leave the
house today right I was really happy to
to to drive a normally a 30- minute
drive it took me over hour and like 15
minutes I loved that drive trying to not
die on icy roads right just to get out
of the house from it that doesn't make
me a terrible dad makes me a
human somebody has you've got I will say
this you got to stop with a comparison
game you because what you're doing it's
almost pornographic you've got these
fantasies about what this thing is
supposed to look like and feel like and
it's not
real moms are allowed to just want to
scream and go running out into the
street moms are allowed to leave the
house and go hang out with their
girlfriends in fact they have to do that
or they'll go mad moms are allowed to go
back to work even part-time to go have
adult
interaction moms are allowed to not have
to sit there and listen to their sister
who is my best friend just sit there and
repeat the whole childhood crap that we
both grew up with yeah moms are allowed
to be annoyed that Dad just seems to be
doing this
perfectly all those things are human
what's more important than those
feelings is what am I going to do next
and have me and my husband sat down and
said all right the marriage we had is
over let's be sad for a
second it's going to be a long time
before I jump up on our kitchen table
when nobody's here and take my shirt off
husband those days are over now at least
for the time being yeah they'll come
back soon but just for this season we
got a build a new marriage what do we
want it to look like and that's the
magic thing the the the nerd word in our
counseling world is called
agency and your body is slowly dragging
you to the backseat of your life in a
sucky life and that's the one you got
thrown into when you were a
kid and I want you to take agency you
are
driving what do we want this thing to
look
like what has to be true in my home so
that I can enjoy
this extraordinary Adventure I'm on
called
motherhood and when some mom is like oh
my gosh I love every second of it you
could say a go set yourself on fire
that's fine and
B good for you that's not
me that's not
me
okay okay is that fair here here's your
homework assignment your homework
assignment is this
your feelings are reminding you of the
way things used to be and they're
working they're doing
great guilt is reminding you of things
that happened when you were a kid and
you were not going to repeat
them neither of those things are telling
you the
truth okay yeah so when you feel a
certain way you feel like I hate all of
this I feel like I want to go running
into the street I want you to take your
hand and I want you to place it right in
your
chest and I want you to ex tail really
big and say thank you body for trying to
take care of
me that makes sense and then we're going
to go do the next right thing and the
only way you can have the next right
thing is if you and your husband get
together by yourself without baby and
you tell him all the things you've told
me we've stumbled into a world that I
don't
love and I want to create a new marriage
now where we still have crazy
adventurous sex and we still have this
but we just have to do it at 8:30
because I'm tired right or I can't have
another human pawing at my body right
now and I know that's awful and sad
here's some things we can do for
intimacy I know you're going to be dying
over there I want you're not g I'm not
let you die here's what that might look
like for us in this particular season By
the Way season three months season six
months season's not four years yeah okay
but all of this is gonna lean back
towards you've got agency you get to
decide what happens in this next
season I'll also strongly suggest two
things number one please please please
please get with a mom's postpartum group
in your area okay I don't have
postpartum there's a
heaviness and it's good to be around
other moms and you don't feel crazy and
you don't feel like you're the only one
and you don't feel like you're the worst
mom who's ever existed and I hate this
cuz my daughter deserves better than me
she does not she deserves her mom
you but but there's something about the
social norming of being around other
people that make you go okay I'm not
bananas what do you do and what do you
do and amongst all that wisdom you're
going to find something that works for
you
awesome and the second thing is I want
you to call a counselor I want you to
meet with somebody because you got some
bricks in your backpack from your
childhood that's going to make
motherhood tough for you that doesn't
mean it's not going to be beautiful and
amazing it's just going to mean cool I
got to learn some new skills that I
don't have in my toolkit awesome that's
what a counselor is going to help you
do but all of these are steps towards
building your amazing
life and you've got agency you get to do
that I'm proud of you for taking the
call for making the call man it's big
time you said some things out loud that
are hard to say and I honor you it's
really really strong of
you and now the scary thing is going to
build something
new I 100% believe in you stay on the
line we're going to hook you up with
building an non-anxious life and on your
past change your future and all the
couples questions for humans decks so
you and your husband can have something
to talk about besides oh my gosh I hate
this and the baby pooped again and again
and again I'm grateful for you calea
we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book build a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right we're back and it's time for
am I the problem go for it Kelly yes all
right this one's Anonymous I'm just
going to read it hello John I have to
admit that I feel a bit silly asking
this question but social media
inevitably plays a role in relationships
nowadays and certainly it's influencing
mine I've asked my boyfriend to change
his status on Facebook to show that he's
in a relationship but he won't do it for
those of y'all that can't see the look
on John's face right now is
fantastic we've been together for over a
year and I brought up this topic to him
a couple of times he does not think this
is important since quote everyone in his
life knows me in person and knows it
we're together just break up with the
dude just break up with the dude it's
over just break up with the dude
following this logic I don't see what
the issue is in his sharing our
relationship on social media is well he
never post pictures with me in any of
his social media platforms and I don't
think he has intention of doing so am I
the problem for needing this type of
validation I think everyone's the
problem here exactly it's not just her
because this is what Society is telling
her request is so
benign let me put it this way if you say
hey we've been together for a year can
you put that on social media and he's
like no it doesn't even matter wait till
you say hey honey I think that I want to
set our child on fire because I haven't
talked to an adult in the last uh five
months can you watch the baby tonight I
ain't doing that I'm watching the game
you think that this request is so small
it's so obnoxiously meaningless that yes
it is dumb that he's fighting you on it
so he's the problem
and is he like what what do
you what a weird world that we've
entered yeah why does that why is that
so important why does that have to be is
he a trophy for you is it like he needs
to display it out there or or I think
he's got something on the side which I
actually think I think that to be true
because I know I know in times in my
life when I I didn't tell people I was
dating I still had a line in the water
but if he says in here everybody that
knows us knows we're dating so here's my
question I'm gonna throw this back on
you a bit
okay you if this was you today uhhuh you
wouldn't post them on social media
because you don't do much social media
right so maybe he's just that guy he's
like I don't need to do that I've not
post my life on social media but but
there's a there's a him saying hey I'm
trying to protect you I don't want
people write mean comments about you I
don't want any of that kind of stuff and
maybe he has too I'm maybe she's like oh
but this is what all my friends need to
see and he says it in here everybody
that knows us knows you and they know
we're dating so I don't think he's
hiding her I think she just needs to not
if it was my husband he would be like
I'm not posting that
nobody if I know why do everybody I know
know that everybody that I care about
knows so why do a bunch of people I
don't know need to exactly why do we
care what they think yes so I think
herba in the club's a problem
here
but I will ask yeah I will say if you
need this sort of external
validation check yourself before you
wreck yourself that's all I'm going to
say in the wise words of Wreck-It
Ralph is that who said that I don't know
who said that who's the originator of
check yourself before you wreck yourself
I don't think it was wreck Ralph is it
Zach
galanakis but I'm pretty sure it wasn't
Wreck-It Ralph hey that's Today's
show man ah gosh my favorite thing about
this show is like I think it's good I
think we have a great show here and it
ends in a car crash almost every time
and I kind of have grown to love it's
like the end of South Park when they
you're waiting to figure out how they
kill Kenny I figure like it's I figure
that's what it's like we did it we
killed Kenny love you guys see you
[Music]
soon